the current low oil price is a boon for
India the country imported 190 million
tons of crude oil in 2014 and while
other emerging economies were suffering
from lower oil revenues India was saving
money the equivalent of 54 billion euros
according to experts the Indian
government wants to use those savings to
plug holes in its budget deficit and to
further boost economic growth India is
already one of the world's
fastest-growing economies since 2014
official figures have put GDP growth at
more than seven percent this year the
country is expecting growth of seven and
a half percent putting India ahead of
China state revenues are badly needed to
expand roads and railways and to improve
the country's health care and education
systems at the same time bureaucracy
needs to be streamlined and public
services made more efficient many
investors are impressed by India's
strong economic performance in recent
months they've gone on a shopping spree
snatching up shares on indian stock
markets investors have noticed that
strong growth figures have not yet
influenced the country stock prices
since april of last year India's msci
index has fallen by fifteen percent
investors hope stock prices will now
start rising and if global oil prices
remain low India's economy is likely to
further benefit if that is the Indian
government is successful with its
ongoing economic reforms